dusting the taken King had just come out
and with it a brand-new heavy weapon is
available
in order to get that new heavy weapon a
badass wielding sword you're gonna need
to first finish the story missions after
completing the story missions you'll
talk to era school then want you to talk
to shacks after talking to shacks you're
gonna get the broken will quest they'll
tell you to gather 25 Hadean flakes and
refine them with ten motes of light into
refined and Haiti in order to get the
Hadean flakes simply go to the
dread-nots and farm these chest
locations
you're going to run into some chests
that require keys and you won't be able
to open them however open all the other
chests and you'll get Haiti employees
once you've found your 25 KTM flakes go
back to checks turn it in and pick the
sword of your choice you can choose an
arc sword a solar sword or a void sword
i toast the ark sword
tell me in the comments below which
sword you think will be best and which
one you kicked stay tuned to games.com
for more destiny the taken king cover
you